>> So, we talked about needing a text editor.
Which one, give any preferences? Which one should we use?
>> I personally use Sublime. I mean, there's,
there's lots of good choices out there but.
>> Okay.
>> Sublime is what I use.
>> So, and is that available in Windows, Mac, both?
>> It's on both, yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So I think I actually use Sublime two.
>> Sublime two, okay.
>> This is, this is a slightly older version so.
>> Okay cool, so I'm going to download for OS X, and I
mentioned that if I had a Windows machine I would get something similar.
>> Yup.
>> And we will let that do it's thing.
Alright, so we just downloaded it and I am going to
search for it now, for some reason it didn't open
automatically. And I am going to drag it over to applications.
And now we're in Applications and if she scroll
down, we've got Sublime. So let's open it up.
>> Oop, there it is.
>> Fine, that's it? We're ready to start going?
>> We're ready.
>> Okay, cool.